this past weekend North American teams
kind of [ __ ] the bed and it's funny I
could be talking about pretty much any
eSport and I'd still be right but there
is something different over the weekend
North American teams at the League of
Legends World Championships when they
combined 5 and 13 in the group stage
that is the worst they've ever performed
under the modern world system it's a
catastrophe and it's got a lot of people
asking how do you fix the dumpster fire
that is n/a League of Legends all right
so why are many fans so upset well
combined any teams went 5 and 13 in the
group stage that is a 27% win rate which
is the worst they've done in five years
but that's not new right na has always
been bad on the international stage or
at least that's how it feels right well
that's not quite the case see actually
any's performance has always been more
middling than abject garbage it's just
felt worse for na fans now though na
isn't that far off from the LMS in terms
of wins in the group stage and they're
not even gonna be a region next year
we're also within spitting distance of
Vietnam and they're a minor region
obviously this result has people memeing
that na doesn't even deserve major
region status and all the major regions
are represented in top eight after all
all three of them but it's also sparked
an interesting discussion about how the
hell do you even go about fixing this
problem the problem is kind of deeply
rooted in na league of legends between
the server and the culture and
management and coaching the point is
there isn't really one clean answer it's
a super complicated issue so let's bring
up the issues one by one and maybe we
can try to figure out something when
this is all over so one of the big
things that get thrown around about why
na isn't that good is their reliance on
imports and that's undeniable every
single na team at Worlds and every team
in the North American summer playoffs or
that matter maxed out their import slots
which is to say that they're not
developing as much homegrown talent not
only that but some teams like TSM and
key liquid are technically running more
than two imports since they have players
who have been around so long that they
don't count as
anymore and that's not to say that na
doesn't develop any homegrown talent at
all c9 has made a lot of headlines over
the years for building up fresh na
players but it's not quite enough
obviously the Academy system helped but
I don't remember the next line obviously
na has also added the Academy system
which has definitely helped get some
players into worlds that we might not
have seen otherwise the Academy put my
career on the map because I started out
in echovox Academy and I got the chance
to play against froggen very very often
it was a huge learning opportunity and I
think since you have like the 10 you ten
LCS players always now and then you have
ten academy players if those players are
taking the job seriously they're always
gonna be able to improve a lot but
clearly the Academy system hasn't done
enough it's gotten those players like
Demonte sure but Demonte is on a team
with two Korean players who let's be
honest aren't landing spots in the lck
anytime soon developing local talent
leads to players who can communicate
better with each other and it leads to
hungrier players who have earned their
spots on the roster not sometimes
washed-up players who got bounced out of
a league that end deserve to be in
anymore then there's the other problem
so OQ kinda sucks in North America
between the fact that and it has the
smallest player base allegations that
any pros have attitude problems when
they're playing solo q and the horrible
ping playing league online in na is
awful
the ping seems fixable and listen na has
the worst ping of any major region in
League of Legends it's an enormous
problem for anybody who's trying to
practice then again it seems kind of
lame to just ask right to build a new
server so that na pros can get better
and the new server isn't gonna fix the
player base issue and the alleged
attitude issue you can't just throw a
bunch of money at the problem and hope
it gets fixed
now there are some suggestions out there
for more radical fixes to the issue
former League of Legends caster and team
owner Monte Cristo's suggested a million
things on Twitter including opening up
certain regions to not count as import
slots in the NA LCS while I don't
necessarily agree with Monte I
understand where he and others are
coming from on this issue see if you
open up the na LCS to also include Latin
American Brazilian Oceanian players well
any players are gonna have to work
harder to earn their spots or they'll be
usurped by a really hung
a player from Australia or something an
amalgamation of a half-dozen regions
says that na doesn't deserve some a
major region anymore and maybe that's
harsh but maybe it's true the issue is
that riot is probably never gonna let
something like that happen see the LCS
is franchised and that means that riot
and the investors we should say the team
owners who have bought shares in the
league have a lot riding on the
continued longevity and success of the
NA LCS not the combination la sa na and
Oceanian league there is another
solution that's being brought up as a
potential solution to any problems make
na play best of threes see in the LCS
right now everyone plays best of ones
all with a regular season and then best
of threes in playoffs and international
tournaments the theory goes that if you
make them play bo3 is all here they'll
be better at best of three is by the
time world's rolls around and yes
European players are playing best of
ones all year - but clearly it hasn't
hampered them in the way that maybe it's
hampered na I guess Europe also has a
thorough system of feeder leagues which
get players from rookies in their local
scenes to starting spots in the LEC
that's works really well for them and
has led to hungrier better players
overall the issue is that na actually
did used to have bo3
and one of the reasons Riot moved away
from them was to increase viewership
when things went franchise and look
viewership matters a lot especially when
you have outside investors who are
looking to make a return on their
investment but you know what also
contributes to viewership players that
win things internationally
maybe I'm just spitballing here but I
have a feeling that if you have a league
in which players go to Worlds and I
don't know win something it'll translate
to viewership back in the regular season
because all of a sudden the regular
season matters and look the easiest
solution to this whole problem is just
to have more international tournaments
but I don't think riot school with that
one either in the situation with more
international tournaments na will be
forced to compete or they'll become
irrelevant eventually they'll just get
good enough to paying with the rest of
the world the problem is that if you
have more international tournaments less
people will probably watch the regular
season games because well they'd rather
watch the best teams in the world
instead of just ten and a teams on top
of that worlds and amasai become far
less special and might have decreased
viewership which again is something that
right absolutely doesn't want alright so
there have been a bunch of solutions and
honestly a lot of them don't seem super
likely so where does that leave us well
really there's no clear solution people
can talk about player attitudes and how
about how coaches need to be tougher all
day but honestly we don't know what goes
on behind the scenes I'm sure that the
players who left Berlin on liquid c9 and
clutch this weekend are extremely upset
and they're probably just gonna grind it
out I don't know if that's the solution
either but here's what I do know the
fans are finally fed up the conversation
has reached a fever pitch and if the
players the coaches the staff the
management of the LCS doesn't do
something soon things are looking pretty
dark for the future of any League of
Legends you know I we've done this so
clean now we don't have an end board
Devon say something stupid no I need you
to say something so we have content for
the end of the video this is what I work
with you understand Devon has a hair
appointment that's a hair appointment